[Music]
well good morning it's our last day here
in Devon I'm sad to leave but the rains
cleared up and I'm gonna do a little bit
of fly-fishing before we take off I've
wanted to fly fish this Creek I just
haven't found the time and we're gonna
see if we can get some native brown
trout
this place is so beautiful there's
actually two rivers on this property and
they come together right behind me a lot
of fishable riverbanks
a couple guests that were here earlier
this week did really well on the native
brown trout in this stream but I was a
little too busy with the carp fishing
but it rained a lot last night and the
visibility is not that great so it's
been making things a little bit
difficult well I'm glad I at least had a
chance to get out here and give it a try
but I need to get back to the house and
make some breakfast because we're
packing up and heading off to the Peak
District here real soon back the house
and amid some breakfast and we're gonna
do some Marmite and toast
this is fermented yeast extract it
smells a little bit like butt but it's
not that bad well there you go it kind
of looks like chocolate spread or like a
caramel it's not it's a very pungent
salty flavor sure it's give it a taste
[Music]
[Applause]
go to our next adventure alright so now
we're going about five hours north to
tide well in the Peak District
middle of the UK boy
[Music]
alright we're digging a little lunch
break welcome to the jungle weep funny
game
[Music]
while we've been driving for six hours
and we just saw this little car Bree
we're gonna stop and get some food well
we got the family fed we got the
bladders empty diapers changed let's get
going
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well we've been driving for 10 and a
half hours we crossed half of England
but we're here at harsh next rental
property and the kids are melting down
so let's get inside this house used to
be a church let's go upstairs
like this place Becca
we got a king bed in here
skylight boys room in here they're
asleep main bathroom check out the
master bedroom
look at that look at this this place is
huge well any rate it is late and we're
exhausted so I'm gonna go to bed and I
will talk to you guys in the morning
good morning everybody and welcome to
our first day in Hyde well it is
absolutely gorgeous got the English
garden back here flying buttresses this
church was opened for the worship of God
April 1888 all right okay this is the
video game room but the boys aren't
allowed to play video games so they're
using their imagination in their mind
the main living area
yes literal cathedral ceilings well
Barney and Jacob are still upstairs
sleeping so me and Tommy I take this
time to go to a tackle shop it will get
some breakfast everybody come on let's
go walk to breakfast do look at this huh
tell me you want to try something this
is called black pudding you ever had
this nothing no it's good
[Music]
well the rest of the family's getting up
and getting ready me and Tommy are gonna
go to angling direct and Sheffield you
ready Tommy oh this this is a mirror
carp right and this right here this is a
tent weighing Slean more carp cradles
over here are fishing Vivi's chairs bed
chairs over there
tons of rods big old fishing poles 30
feet Plus these things cost thousands of
dollars remote-controlled boats for your
baby fish Karen antiseptic spray first
aid kit for your fish that is so light
well I bought two cat fishing rods - cat
fishing reels at a bunch of odds and
ends because this week we're going to
target wels catfish so pretty excited
about that but we gotta get back to the
house mom's waiting for it Oh
oh it's a little drizzly outside but
we're gonna go to [ __ ] burrow to [ __ ]
burrow good bro subbu bro well we pulled
over at this scenic overlook here and
we're gonna have Becca try our hand at
driving here in England this may be my
last entry in the V log as we might all
die are you excited to try driving on
the left-hand side of the road for the
first time this trip I'm gonna
intentionally get in on the left side so
the pedals are the same gas on the right
brake on the left turn signals are
extremely optional here that's your your
gear shift you're driving
turning there you go you're doing it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we're here at Shugborough
estates and farms and we're just doing
whatever Melanie and Becca want to do
it'll be fun
[Music]
[Music]
guys look at this is where they did
their laundry that's what the soap look
like look at this they put the irons up
again they build a fire in there oh
we're all pretty hungry but we wanted to
eat something a little different so we
stopped in at this Bangladeshi Indian
restaurant chicken biryani butter
chicken tikka masala oh yeah I tell you
what guys I was so in the mood for a
curry and that just hit the spot well
we're back at the house we're full of
Indian food we've had a great day but we
are going to bed well welcome to another
beautiful Sunday guys we're leaving our
little church here to go to another
church and you can hear the village
church bells going off
all right well my kids have destroyed
another church and we had a grand time
but now we are going to go to Sherwood
Forest and Nottingham that's just down
the street not too far so we're gonna go
check that out and the boys are very
excited about that
okay we've discovered a new road trip
treat it's called a yum-yum it's
basically a croissant covered in like a
toffee syrup it's taste a little bit
like a cronut if you're familiar with
that it is delicious it's not
pretentious it's always okay we've now
driven two Nottinghamshire to Sherwood
Forest the home of whoo and we're gonna
hike to the major oak the major oak is
like this thousand year old oak tree
that they believe that real legend has
it is where Robin Hood and his men
camped out and it also one British tree
of the year many years in a row so it's
a notable tree so we're gonna check this
out
yeah
[Music]
you taking your brother here this is the
major oh and look at that beauty and
this is the Robin Hood festival of
course they've got a little archery
range over here gotta have that Nathan
are you climbing up there
[Music]
look at if this force is just pockmarked
with these ancient trees right there are
you an outlaw off there Thomas Thomas
what happened here shirt yeah well this
is a pretty fun little faster we had no
clue this was here we just walked over
to go see the tree so let see it gets
over the fence but allows it to keep
animals in yeah let your dog through all
right
the boys are watching Robin Hood on the
TV this is just how we're spending a
nice easy Sunday and I'll see you guys
tomorrow
this is bliss Hill Farms it's basically
a historical recreation of a town it's
kind of like Williamsburg in Virginia
only this is the Midlands England
version see they meet Loxy
yes we look at those tools on there see
yeah it's where they poor cast iron
steel parts and see all those things up
on the wall
that's for using with the power hammer
giant slave block
yeah yeah cobbler all right we just
bought some old-timey fish and chips
that are fried and beef renderings and I
got a bunch of old-timey sodas dandelion
burdock curiosity Cola
rose lemonade and Mandarin don't know
more grabbing the Ducks okay all right
I'm going to try the dandelion burdock
soda here it reminds me a little bit of
that scene see NOLA that Latino Cola
it's like fruity with a hint of black
licorice like red licorice and black
licorice mixed together
that old blast furnace are you guys
going to school
these are old tablets I only got one app
[Music]
my name is mr. Itami so tell me what do
you think of the class never what did
you think of your first day at school
[Music]
[Music]
see you guys can knock coconut off oh
yeah
I'm sorry
did you have fun yeah a little lady with
a little baby did you have fun my
favorite foul boys horses the horse is
all right we ready to go a few miles
down the road and check out the iron
bridge Jameson fish off the bridge
[Music]
well we're in downtown Buxton and we
decided that we really want Italian food
tonight well we left the kids in the car
with aunt Melanie
they will kill her if we don't get back
in about 10 minutes
we're here to go we're gonna walk
through Buxton here and see some of the
historic sights
there's the Buxton Opera House there we
go the Derbyshire dome the largest
freestanding dome in England apparently
we haven't met a single American on this
whole trip so far everyone keeps saying
what brings you out settle up so this is
like the georgian crescent some duke
built a palace here and it's old
Georgian time buildings and stuff and we
finish our five-minute walk of Buxton
behind the Town Hall building which was
built in 1888 the same year as a church
were staying in
there's been another fun an amazing day
but it is time to get the boys to bed
and I will see you in the morning well
good morning everybody and we are going
to go get some breakfast and ties well
me and Nathan are headed to home farm
fisheries about an hour southwest of us
and we're gonna try to catch our very
first wels catfish are you excited
Nathan alright looks like we're here oh
wow this place is gorgeous yeah gently I
see a little baby birdy probably he's
getting ready to fly yeah we don't know
where his nest is oh look at that he's
gonna learn how to fly this is our cabin
buddy this is an amazing spot look at
this look how picturesque this is and
we've got electricity in the cabin the
guys have loaned me a bed chair and the
chair unhooking mat swaying swings yeah
we just need to get some sleeping bags
and we should be okay fishing republic
this is one of Britain's bigger fishing
chain stores as disturbingly OnPoint
yeah this one looks pretty decent what
you got a pet maggot mr. maggot
those guys are still died oh man I'll I
don't think that's how child safety
restricts are supposed to work hey wake
up there buddy well I got both my rods
in the water got them in good spot
you're just gonna sit here and relax a
little bit and see what happens
Nathan's watching his shows snuggled in
a bag eating pizza things are going good
for him
so what you're telling me is that Batman
got bit by a radioactive bat and that's
what turned him into Batman these guys
got a wels catfish on the man you ever
been at it long either have you those
guys were in the water ten minutes and
they just pulled out a 24 pound wels
catfish so I just need to put my bait in
front of a fish they're in here yeah you
see the line see the line bounce like
that yeah that was a bite you gotta feel
it free love freely that one you go get
the net
oh I'm sorry need well you did a great
job real in that fish I'm sorry I lost
it buddy well it's getting pretty late
so I think I bet he could go into bed
but I got the alarm set up so if
anything bites while I'm sleeping should
wake me up but I'll see you guys in the
morning
well me and Nathan had a load of fun and
we had that one fish on but other than
that it's been dead quiet seen tons of
fish just not bite my hook so that tells
me got a bait problem so we're gonna
head home and spend the day sightseeing
with mommy and aunt Melanie and Jacob
hood and all that and we're gonna hit a
bait shop on the way and see we can't
pick up some different baits and then
we're gonna come back here later this
afternoon and try this again tonight all
right
Nathan's got his pet maggots poor little
guy missed VI all he wants to do is
cuddle where are we headed Chatsworth
out and its famous why no because it was
mr. Darcy's house in the newer Pride and
Prejudice movie come on Melanie I hear
the house belongs to an eligible
bachelor more than ten thousand pounds a
year
[Music]
so you guys have to stay close which
waiting should we go I told you this
would end in certain dude yeah we got
here before the scurvy set in I got a
dominate in the back of the van here and
we're headed back to home farm fisheries
gonna try again for a wels catfish this
is just an amazing place to do a little
father-son camping fishing trip the boys
are just loving this check it out that's
beautiful then we'll go to hardcore
fishermen well don't it's a roach cuz
that's a new species for you alright
get to bed buddy it's late that is a
beautiful fish look at that here you go
bud well I don't know if that thing was
even ten pounds but it's a wels catfish
and a new personal best brand new
species super excited
Oh Nathan just fill out the boys are
sitting here eating a hot bacon sandwich
thanks to our very kind neighbor yep
you like that Tom nicely a little red
fin little perk Tom's having more fun
fishing for those little fish with this
cane pole then landon any massive fish
well we need to pack up a little bit go
beat mama back at the cottage and we are
gonna go do some sightseeing if I could
stay awake Melanie where we doing line
park the widest place famous that's the
right answer from the original pricey
south oh look side left side of the road
all right well I haven't slept properly
the last couple nights so I am gonna
take a little nap in the car but uh
Becca can do some filming for me ya know
I'm probably gonna fall down not sure if
we can film in the house what happens
delighted to make your acquaintance
madam delighted sir you go there's a
Sergei
oh yeah there's water in there your
stand there I'll take your picture okay
okay Nathan hold still no no don't climb
on the railing just just hold still just
just stand by your brother and just hold
still no he's using his pencil he got in
from the house to be a unicorn and
occasionally stabs people maybe I like
it I'm gonna keep going we gotta hurry
we're gonna run to the car and it's
gonna be awesome and then we're gonna go
to another place that Amelia wants to go
to have you been little friends well we
visited lime Park it was fun so what's
the name of this place we're going to do
40 big all right that's a cotton mill or
something well dig he was asleep so I
might stay in the car with him Becca do
some more video
but we're gonna go into this old mill
mistress
but over your head and if you can beat
right here you're old enough to work
here so if you can beat your left ear it
means that you would have been about the
age of nine Oh Nathan do you want to
work in the mill pretty interesting huh
guys this is where I think the owner of
the mill lived you want to go see okay
[Music]
and now totally filthy oh my gosh look
at his butt he must be one of those
Nichols boys all right well I'm getting
ready to head out for another day
fishing and the boys are playing with
the neighborhood kids they're having so
much fun I feel bad about tearing them
away sorry bud
it's our final night there's our last
chance to catch a big wels catfish
okay guys what you guys want to see the
bag of worms that is a lot of worms we
are not holding back there we go a nice
little wels catfish feels about eight
pounds now they're fun fish to catch
well there we go two wels catfish
neither one of them particularly big but
both well good morning guys it's the end
of our fishing trip here we're headed to
Scotland today and we've got to get on
the road and get an early start on it
we just had a ball this is an absolute
beautiful fishery if you want to come to
home farm fisheries in the Midlands of
England I'll put a link in the
description thanks for watching I sure
hope you enjoyed this video if you want
to see part three of our three-week tour
to the UK don't forget to check the link
in the description and don't forget to
click Subscribe because we put out new
videos every Saturday morning
[Music]